because you mentioned like the top gets
bigger with empires
and you start taking things for granted
is the some of this just human nature
so the concern with with china
with autocratic nations
the concern with the
the third reich
the soviet union
was that
fundamentally at the individual level
the humans involved at the top
they start becoming they're starting to
lose touch with reality
in a way that
no longer makes them i guess that's the
representation of the flexibility that
you're referring to well i'm i mean in a
democracy um you could change you can go
as far left or as far right you can
change the leaders easily and so the
people don't become
um you know they pretty much only have
themselves to blame uh yeah you know and
one of the problems of that is they may
not choose the best leaders
um but they um they have that
flexibility so if vote and
you get what you wanted
in the case of the autocratic let's say
leaders and then the movement from
democracies to autocracies um what you
see normally that movement is that one
of the systems is it is not working
let's say the democracy is not
effectively everybody's arguing with
each other and nobody's getting anything
done and
you know like mussolini the trains are
not running on time and that would be
the example jesus this place has gotten
chaotic will somebody get into control
and then they then you get the
autocratic um and then he's autocratic
enough to boss people around and um and
then you follow those kinds of orders
and it's like maybe a ceo in a powerful
company watering around and that could
work well or it could work badly you
know most
um companies
are run as um
like autocracies in a sense you know
there's the hierarchy and you the
command economy and that kind of thing
um and now that can work well or not um
but then what quite often when you get
the populist autocratic their
personality is something that they want
to fight
um and they become more nationalistic
and they tend to become more
militaristic and human nature at that
stage
um
lends itself to fighting there's an arc
here that when we think
it's we think of a country
um and we say we when we think of a
country
um it's not true it's not like that
there are individuals who change
one generation dies and another
generation comes along
and one of those arcs is that um
um the ones who have been through war
don't want to go to war
and are more happily you know willing to
abide by whatever the rules are
as you get farther along into that cycle
and you get a new generation and they
forget about wars and the horrors of
wars then they um
then they want to uh
fight and so you're seeing right now
the emergent of fight for right and and
what that means is you see it internally
uh fight
where are you and fight for that thing
and they mean fight
and then into externally fight are you
going to be uh the strong one who will
fight and win and that develops on both
sides this fight and win and each side
is cheering each other on into
a war but that's comes by those who
really have not experienced war because
it comes in their part of their lifetime
humans are fascinating
humans are fascinating and by the way
human nature has not changed
over the
thousands of years so it's the it's so
interesting because like in doing this
study and it comes across in the study
it's like watching the same movie over
and over again
you you know you see the ark and you see
it happen over and over again the only
things that seem to change are the
clothes people wear and the technologies
they use
uh
yeah and then somebody probably will
disagree with you about the clothes
maybe there's also cycles within
fashions maybe we're not even creative
there
you